les plus grandes émeutes qu'on est
enregistré dans les pays occidentaux
sont associés avec des brutalités
policières avec des des actions de
police agressives comme à l'époque
Margaret Sacher en en
Grande-Bretagne ou bien avec des décès
au cours des opérations de police c'est
là j'ai fait la liste he parce que les
principaux encore une fois c'est c'est
le Royaume-Uni la France mais j'ai
rajouté aussi parce que c'est le cas le
le Canada et le Québec particulièrement
à Montréal en 2008 à aussi en 2008 et à
chaque fois on retrouve le même
phénomène donc il y a une régularité et
nous on a enfin les les je suis plus
politiste que sociologue mais on a une
croyance dans le fait que bah les
régularités nous disent quelque chose
des liens de causalité hein je parle pas
de causalité directe parce que c'est
plus compliqué que ça mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que le les les brutalités
policières sont un déclencheur et encore
une fois c'est pas lié au système
politique on n'est pas le système grec
on n'est pas ETA il y a il y a un
phénomène qui est qui est lié à la
fonction symbolique que la police
remplit dans une société c'estàd que
quand une une organisation qui a pour
fonction la sécurité arrive à à une dans
des situations où elle va tuer une
personne la plupart du temps ou la
brutaliser désarmé et qu'on va avoir des
preuves vidéos de ces événements il va y
avoir un choc moral qui va entraîner une
mobilisation qui lui-même va entraîner
qui elle-même va entraîner d'autres
choses